c'est curieux mon impression vous
hésitez tout ça interrogé thierry roland
il ya quelque chose mais je aller
bloquer qui vous gène 182 c'est à vous
marie vous n'avez pas enlever votre
micro je pense que vous allez le faire
elle voulait me garder donnez moi votre
micro trouver le gardez vous avez vous
installé et tiré au sort tout de suite
un petit billet que brigitte va me
donner voilà qui est fait alors le thème
et vous allez commencer avec pierre
bachelet c'est le pain top chrono une
minute pierre vacher les premières
questions pourquoi mon choix du pain
pour grossir nicole croisille que
mettons sur du pain du beurre
thierry rolland sont le pain chez le
boulanger yogi citez moi ne pas 25
yves lecoq lamy que peut-il y avoir
où peut-on trouver du pain et la
question des sables sur la table est ce
que le pape est d'accompagner seule
question dany saval marie vite je le
préfet le pays
vous aimez le pas comment grille et
daniel prévost présent je ne mange pas
de pain moi j'ai foutu par un petit
déjeuner
croyez-moi croyez moi ça n'est pas
facile du tout de trouver 10 questions
très simples sur un sur un thème donné
merci marie vous avez gagné tout de même
162 supplémentaire donc brigitte va vous
remettre dans quelques instants